welcome to this video new game started
against alex from joni i don't know him
is located near me but I don't really
know the sky okay I've got a queen's
gambit he's going for the Slav I could
play Quincy to didn't do that for a
while or queen bee three I may be queen
bee three I didn't play this so much
okay his immediate play immediately
playing e6 yeah so we get into a queen's
gambit declined type of position okay
yeah that's probably all right always
need to be a bit a bit cautious here
with Queen a five checks and stuff like
that because of this slightly loose
bishop on g5 there are sometimes very
stupid ways to to loose pieces ins and
such who came playing whoo Kreator I
play rook d 1 this is very often a good
term a good way to prevent see 585
yeah if you take some young you wouldn't
win tempe would be five I don't know I
could play c5 but this doesn't make so
much sense in connection with the rookie
won okay probably you will take now
anyway I'm so a three ball maybe when
with a temple in some way compared to a
bishop move and then takes I think you
will take no all 97 we can play 97 this
is a ok yeah ok this is also also
possible I rather advanced and then
exchange and now we I need to I need to
play before otherwise this whole thing
doesn't make much sense aha yeah this is
so of course the typical break the
question is amiss has some technical way
to do it if I take care probably now G
form so just protected
so an interesting interesting position
should I'm yeah I just think I should
maybe I can try to preserve this bishop
on g3 on if he wants to yeah like night
h5 now we should be to exactly that I
have this some slightly more stable
structure on the edge file prefer that
to just um having the porn on h2 so
let's just prevent a five for the time
being and then prepare a form hmm ready
Bishop c4 yeah maybe maybe he wants to
play Bishop reform
hmm i don't mind that so much actually
with the the lightscribe bishops
exchanged um the c6 bishop this is six
pawn essa is very easily attacked but
some it's a bit of a case of this famous
some quote of romanian grandmaster Shuba
the bed bed bishops protect good pawns
it's really one of the funniest chess
course i know it's all very often true
basically okay so now we get a queen
trade and I believe this is excellent
for me I have fun play on da phone I can
just go rook a3 rook a 1 and what is he
doing it can take on a4a true gate 4
there's a six week and I also night a
five ideas attacking the c6 pawn so the
Queen trade should be really good
check hmm interesting
I don't mind really on f3 what is this
thing doing and started taking much ok
and now just double here here and sits
probably doesn't matter double first so
that I provoke him to move the rook of
the fo now it probably needs to remove
it and now I can enter be 7 a-7 95 and
at the NC sixes the 12 to go you know is
trying for counter sacrifices so pretty
pretty decent idea ok I must be regards
to not play Knight a5 too early
on the other hand it's it's really a PCM
defeat sacrifices so I need to learn at
some point where you just just do that I
can I can also is this possible yeah
let's just do that nitey to and protect
all this and then at the end play Knight
a5 I just then take it without allowing
a route h6 SS counter flame yeah hmm did
you have any way to to avoid that
I know it looks passive but I don't want
him to get so much counterplay night h2
don't believe it yeah but it's happening
what can you do time warning aah Wow
earth did I let him out of this
check check yeah I should probably just
resign him but it always some yeah tough
to do if you had had such a great
position yeah yeah okay we'll manage
like God made me got that I played to
pass off for him just just just crap how
I did this ah ok I just need to allow
this bloody sacrifice I didn't I didn't
want to yeah of course I can just play
95 it's clear I thought okay let's try
to get rid of all counter play first and
this way he he got some he got all play
like I can just do that it's clear I
just Roxy 76 it's and I win this I
didn't want to allow any any crappy
sacrifices yeah I thought I shouldn't I
shouldn't really do that but okay this
is just nothing this is what I had more
second thoughts yeah yeah and resins 94
yeah it's just nothing and the way I
played this here it was probably still
winning but um he got he got a
substantial quarter play and now we
really got got an edge should be three
was even better
I can play rook each one actually and
still oh that's still I'm okay yeah i
actually just miscounted he is quick
enough to to cover the porn yes what
this sport is badly thanks for watching